all right but we are going to begin with
the debt ceiling that showdown in
Washington this is something that could
have a major impact on your money and
Global markets and here's what's going
on the treasury is expected to confirm
today that the U.S has reached its
so-called debt ceiling that is the
nation's legal borrowing limit
Republicans want Cuts before they vote
to increase it well Democrats are saying
that that risks say government default
which would be a very bad thing indeed
Scott McFarland is on Capitol Hill he's
following it for us Scott the more
people learn about this it seems like
the more they want to shake their head
good morning
absolutely Tony good morning emergency
measures go in place today from the U.S
treasury Department to give Congress a
few months to raise the debt ceiling but
the political fight during that period
could have big consequences on the U.S
economy
in Washington a dangerous standoff is
looming later today the treasury
Department is expected to announce it's
taking Extraordinary Measures to prevent
America from defaulting on its debt
those include shifting money between
government accounts the treasury will
also temporarily hold off payments to
some Federal Employee Retirement plans
and health funds for retired postal
workers to give Congress a few more
months to raise the debt ceiling
Republicans who control the U.S house
and particularly those who demanded
concessions from Kevin McCarthy before
he became speakers say they want
promises Washington will cut its
expenses before raising the debt limit
why wouldn't we sit down now set a
budget set a path to get us to a
balanced budget and let's start paying
this debt off but the White House says
it won't negotiate over such a vital
thing this is something that should be
happening without conditions 5 29 is
your total at his hardware store in
Maryland Bill Hart has little margin for
error to remain profitable and to keep
all 50 of his employees it is a big
responsibility
would you're responsible for this many
people's livelihoods and families which
means he doesn't want the uncertainty
which could be coming just last week I
purchased for Halloween and Christmas so
in this business you have to plan way
out especially when you're getting
things shipped over from overseas
Virginia Democrat Abigail spamberger
says just the possibility of
brinksmanship could rattle the Market's
401ks and trigger a recession leaders
within the financial sector or
economists business owners have already
begun to really you know explain and
Ring the Alarm bells of why this is an
issue
the nation's debt limit is 31.4 trillion
dollars but without more borrowing the
government can't pay for expenses it's
already incurred the last time Congress
nearly breached the debt ceiling was
2011 and it caused a downgrade of the
U.S credit rating and a shock to the
stock market Nate
Scott thank you